the left celebrates as federal
prosecutors talk about inciting
President Trump
president from swivels and clocks James
Comey and the White House chief of staff
John Kelly is out I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
so you had yourself a busy little
weekend it may be your last that was the
actual original lyric to to like to have
yourself a merry little Christmas was
have yourself a merry little Christmas
it may be your last
I'm not kidding that's the original I
know irrelevant but now we are back from
the weekend and we have so much news to
get to so much news you can feel your
head exploding with anticipation don't
worry we'll get to all of it in just one
second first we have to talk about the
best gift you can give this holiday
season my great man kraits knows what
dudes love they've hundreds of unique
quality gifts that he is guaranteed to
love you're looking at getting a dude in
your family one of your friends a great
gift for Christmas for New Year's well
then you need to go check out man crates
because they've got things like the
whiskey appreciation crate that has he
personalized to cancer and personalized
glasses I have that one even though I've
said I don't like whiskey in the past
suddenly man crates has converted me and
the exotic meats crate they've got the
knife making kit the grillmaster crates
they've got sports crates they've got
everything and all of these gifts ship
in these great containers so many of
them shipped in a sealed wooden crate
with a crowbar so he has to prove his
manliness every time he opens up his
mind great he has to pry it open with
this little crowbar that comes along
with it it's really fun in front of
everyone he got to humiliate all your
friends and with man crates you're
giving him more than gifts you're giving
him a gift experience that you will all
remember and remember every man can a
man crate comes with a 100% satisfaction
guarantee listeners to the show by one
gift and you get the second gift for 25%
off when you go to my crates calm slash
Ben that offers only for the holidays
buy one gift get the second 25% off at
my crates calm slash Ben once more
that's mine crates calm slash Ben check
that up and get that special holiday
deals so much goodness
to begin your week okay so so much
badness to begin the President of the
United States his week the president had
a very very rough Friday afternoon on
Friday afternoon there are two major
legal memos regarding president Trump's
former personal attorney Michael Cohen
that dropped the first concerned the
Muller investigations recommended
sentencing for Michael Kohn I'll analyze
now on in just a second the second is
the more important one this one
concerned the Southern District of New
York's recommended sentencing for
Michael Kohn in light of his test
monie regarding president Trump's
campaign and payoffs to women including
former paramour stormy Daniels the
president's bad taste in women has
finally caught up with him here is the
problem
hey the SD NY investigation is all about
campaign finance reform the Moller
investigation is all about trump russia
links as you might guess the campaign
finance stuff has more legs than the
Trump Russia stuff at least as this
point so here's what we can take away
from the SDN while Southern District of
New York filing against Michael Cohen
first they don't like Michael Cohen very
much in the this memo is written like a
prosecutorial argument it's written like
a prosecuting document as Andrew
McCarthy points out that is not atypical
for this sort of filing according to the
filing cone committed four distinct
federal crimes over a period of several
years it was motivated to do so by
personal greed and repeatedly used his
power and influence for deceptive ends
they refused to call him a cooperating
witness meaning they didn't really want
to mitigate his sentence they want a
sentence that reflects a modest downward
variance from a statutory period of
between 51 and 63 months so that means
they want to put him away for three to
four years in federal prison at minimum
they are going after Cohen for illegal
campaign contributions here is where
things get dicey for President Trump the
wages of stormy Daniels for Michael
Cohen are jail the SG NY is accusing
Michael Cohen of having a campaign email
address and of advising the campaign's
they're saying that basically he worked
for the campaign without formally
working for the campaign they claim that
Cohen quote played a central role in two
similar schemes to purchase the rights
to stories each from women who claim to
have had an affair with individual one
individual one would be Trump so as to
suppress the stories and thereby prevent
them from influencing the election if
you recall what happened is that
President Trump saw that there were a
couple of stories that were gonna break
one from Karen McDougal a former
paramour and one from stormy Daniels a
former paramour and he then instructed
according to Michael Cohen he instructed
Michael Cohen to go pay off the National
Enquirer to go buy these stories from
these women and then bury them now this
sort of arrangement had existed
apparently for a long time between
President Trump and the National
Enquirer which is something that we're
going to get back to you in just a
second the SD NY says that this was a
campaign finance issue why do they say
this is a campaign finance issue because
they say basically this was a campaign
expenditure it was an expenditure
designed to prevent these stories from
coming out in the middle of the campaign
and thereby impacting
the campaign itself and so President
Trump instructed Michael Cohen to make
these payments and then did not report
them to the Federal Elections Commission
and this constitutes a federal crime not
only on the part of Michael Cohen but on
the part of President Trump now there
are a couple of problems with this legal
theory problem number one with this
legal theory that would mean that
President Trump had to know he was
violating campaign law the actual
standard for intent in campaign finance
law that bears criminal penalties is
extremely high and number two is unclear
whether it is actually a campaign
expenditure to pay hush money to a woman
because let's say that you're running
campaign and then the campaign had
actually paid hush money to a woman
would that be legal unclear unclear
whether you can really claim as a
campaign expenditure paying hush money
to a woman in your in your circle or
whether that would constitute an illegal
campaign donation or an illegal campaign
expenditure well if it's illegal to use
campaign money to pay off a woman then
the only other way to pay off a woman
would be to not do it as campaign money
which is what happened here that's the
case that's been made by many including
a former FEC Commissioner we'll get back
to that in just a second what does this
mean well it means that they are going
to go after Trump himself for campaign
violations there's no question the SDN
why is targeting president from four
indictments he will find himself in a
court of law if it is possible in fact
to prosecute the President of the United
States that is a dicey constitutional
issue it is not clear whether the
President of the United States is immune
to prosecution Bill Clinton was not
prosecuted he was made subject to a
civil suit which is not quite the same
thing in the Paula Jones case a criminal
indictment of a sitting president
provides serious constitutional problems
because you could then have a state
prosecuting a president putting the
president behind bars anytime you don't
like the president you can have a
malicious prosecution for a state crime
in any state in the Union and then that
could be used to lock up a president so
typically speaking constitutional
scholars have suggested that presidents
are immune to criminal prosecution and
that the proper measure for going after
a president is impeachment and then
there are folks who suggest that
President Trump would then be prosecuted
theoretically after he left office but
all of this is speculating as to what
happens as to this investigation itself
what is not real speculation at this
point is that the SD NY is gearing up
for a criminal indictment of President
Trump that will either be leveraged
after he leaves office or they will
attempt to cram down even while he's
president the FDNY says that Cohan quote
acted with the intent to influence the
presidential election that he
coordinated with campaign members and
that he acted in coordination with and
at the direction of individual one it's
that last language that matters to
President Trump the SD NY is claiming
that Michael Cohen only acted because
President Trump instructed him to break
the law the SD NY is essentially
accusing Trump of ordering a violation
of campaign finance law Cohen also did
not talk to the SD NY about ancillary
matter so this is all that they are
giving him that really matters now I
want to get to Andy McCarthy has a piece
in National Review all about the
takeaway from the sentencing memorandum
he comes to the same conclusion I do
which that the SD NY is likely to indict
President Trump here is what Andy
McCarthy says and remember Andy McCarthy
has been very Pro the president in terms
of his legal reasoning this is not
coming from somebody who wants to quote
unquote get the president he says
prosecutors would not have done this if
the president was not on their radar
screen indeed if the president was not
implicated I suspect they would not have
prosecuted Cohen for campaign finance
violations at all those charges had
negligible impact on the jail time Cohen
faces which is driven by the more
serious offenses of tax and financial
institution fraud involving millions of
dollars more over campaign finance
infractions are often settled by
payments of an administrative fine not
turn into felony prosecutions to be sure
federal prosecutors in New York City
have charged them as felonies before
most notably against Dinesh D'Souza in
marked contrast though when it was
discovered that Barack Obama's 2008
presidential campaign was guilty of
violations involving nearly 2 million
dollars the Obama Justice Department
decided not to prosecute instead they
find in my 400 grand
nevertheless the sentencing memo in
Cohen's case reads like an ode to
campaign finance laws and here is what
McCarthy says he says President Trump
cannot feel too comfortable upon reading
the memo nor can the Trump legal team
take solace when the campaign finance
charges switch Cohen pled guilty are
scrutinized thus far the team has been
dismissive noting that the campaign
finance law has different standards for
a candidate than for other donors
contributions such as Cohen's made were
limited in 2016 with $2,700 donation but
there is no limit on a candidate
spending thus the argument goes even if
the hush money payments vastly exceeded
Cohen's legal ceiling Trump himself
could have made them legally but there
are thought flaws in this theory to
begin with the campaign finance laws do
not just prescribe limits on spending
they mandate disclosure and this is what
I was saying earlier about the fact that
President
if he worked out with Michael Cohen how
to pay off stormy Daniels and then
didn't inform the Federal Elections
Commission that in and of itself could
have been the crime the sentencing memo
for Cohen argues that the hush money
payments were not merely unreported it
states the cone and the Trump
Organization the president's company
went to great lengths to conceal them by
fraudulent bookkeeping equally
significant Cohn was not charged with
merely making illegal donations as Andy
McCarthy he was charged in the first
campaign finance count with causing a
company to make illegal donations this
would be the offense centering not on
stormy Daniels but on former Playboy
model Karen McDougal
prosecutors have already given immunity
to a bunch of American media executives
National Enquirer executives presumably
they're doing that in order to get them
to testify against President Trump so
here is what McCarthy suggests he
suggests that Trump may have a solid
defense here he says that there there a
couple of ways that the president could
defend himself first campaign finance
violations have a high proof threshold
for intent as I was saying earlier
President Trump could argue that because
there was no spending limit on his
contributions he did not think about the
campaign finance implications much less
willfully violate them there is
furthermore a significant question about
whether hush money payments qualify as
in-kind campaign contributions there's
nothing illegal per se in making a
nondisclosure agreement they're quite
common the criminal law comes into play
only if the nondisclosure payment is
deemed a donation for purposes of
influencing a political campaign and so
Trump could claim I think rightly that
he's been making payoffs like this his
entire career so this is not having to
do with the election whether or not
there was an election he was going to
attempt to pay off the National Enquirer
to silence Stormy's Daniels and to
silence Karen McDougal so it has nothing
to do with the election so the payment
is not a donation if it was made for an
expense that was independence of the
campaign that is money that would have
had to be paid even if there were no
campaign there are other salient issues
as well Justice Department guidance says
the sitting president can't be indicted
if President Trump were to be re-elected
in 2020 he would not be out until 2024
and then the statute of limitations
would have elapsed but the bottom line
is that the president is now in peril of
indictment again that doesn't mean that
he actually will be criminally indicted
it doesn't mean that if he's indicted he
actually has to face down on our trial
it doesn't mean any of those things but
it could provide the hook for the left
to hang its hat upon when it comes to
impeachment Adam Schiff again a man who
puts up his
tent outside all of the green rooms in
Washington DC was on Face the Nation
over the weekend he's incoming chief
probably of the House Intelligence and
Oversight Committee he says the
president Trump now faces the prospect
of jail time there's a very real
prospect that on the day Donald Trump
leaves office the Justice Department may
indict him that he may be the first
president in quite some time to face the
real prospect of jail time okay so he's
making this case and this is in a way
actually cutting against Democrats
political interest because the more they
push this the more they say that the
president is facing jail time the more
it becomes incumbent on them to file
impeachment charges against the
president as soon as they enter office
and as will see the Democrats already
implying they're gonna do so now what
will be the political blowback for all
of that unclear typical kind of
conventional wisdom holds that when you
try to impeach a president and fail the
president gains in strength going into
his next election I'm not sure that's
the case but I'll explain that in just
one second first let's talk about how
you gonna send all of your gifts this
Christmas so this Christmas sending out
a lot of gifts to friends and family it
could cost you a fortune but it
shouldn't because you can be using
stamps.com instead of going over to the
post office and having to schlep all
those gifts into the line and waiting
over there the post office is great but
you can be doing all of this stuff from
home stamps kaam brings all the services
of the u.s. post office directly to your
desktop by and prints official US
postage for any letter any package any
class of mail using your own computer
and printer and then the mail carrier
just picks it up no trips to the post
office required it could not be easier
print postage any day any time stamps
comm is always open and not only to
stamps calm save you time it saves you
money because stamps calm helps you
print the right amounts of postage every
time never overpay again and with stamps
commie get discounts on postage you
can't get even at the post office with
all the time and money you will save
stamps calm is a fantastic gift you can
get yourself this holiday season will
use stamps calm here at the daily wear
offices when it comes to sending out
gifts my family uses stamps calm right
now you too can enjoy stamps calm with a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus postage and the digital scale
without long term commitments go to
stamps calm click on the microphone at
the top of the home page type in promo
code Shapiro that is stamps calm enter
promo code Shapiro to go check it out
stamps calm promo code Shapiro for that
special deal alright so the Democrats
are painting themselves into a corner
because now if they believe
Trump has committed a criminal offense
they're almost forced to file
impeachment charges in the house against
President Trump so here is
representative Jerrold Nadler he is
making exactly that case over the
weekend to Jake Tapper on CNN certainly
they'd be impeachable offenses because
even though they were committed before
the president became president they were
committed in in in in the service of
fraudulently obtaining the office that
would be the the that would be an
impeachable offense okay so he's not the
only one making this case Denny heck
another representative from Nevada he
was on CNN as well making exactly the
same case the president should be
indicted do you think there's now enough
evidence to prove that President Trump
committed a crime possibly even a felony
yes okay why well because Michael Cohen
pleaded guilty to it and because they
named the president individual one which
I don't think they would have done in
any way shape or form they weren't
required to reference the president but
they did so and I have to assume that
that is on the basis of significant and
material corroborating evidence that
they have collected okay so suffice it
to say that if these crimes had been
committed by a Democrat while President
Obama was in office let's say President
Obama had done all of this would
President Obama be facing jail time from
his own Justice Department no because
President Obama's Justice Department was
his wingman for people who are saying
that this just proves how corrupt the
Trump administration is remember Trump's
DOJ has been allowed to go through with
full investigations Obama's DOJ was
basically protecting him every step of
the way for those who say that there is
no incitement possible here remember
that John Edwards was indicted the
former presidential candidate for the
Democrats was indicted on similar
charges it's difficult to prove these
charges it's very difficult to suggest
the president is going to go to jail
because he paid hush money to a woman
again
John Edwards and the difference in that
case particularly is that John Edwards
his own people were willing to stand up
for him in this particular case the
Muller investigation the SDN why have
cracked down on Michael Cohen to the
extent that he's broken turning
witnesses against President Trump is the
key to getting president Trump indicted
is he protected from indictment past the
election yes I think that it's difficult
to read the Justice Department
guidelines and say President Trump is
going to jail while still elected
president of the United States with that
said does this provide the in
for an impeachment it certainly does in
a second we'll discuss what that means
for the Democrats so as I say typical
conventional wisdom holds that the
Democrats would be worse off if they
impeach President Trump than if they
just sort of sit there and fulminate
about him it's still two years away from
the election it's still December of 2018
the next election only happens in
November of 2020 which is a long time if
we've learned anything during the Trump
era it's that every day lasts a thousand
years so if the Democrats were to try
and drag this out all the way through
November of 2020 I'm not sure that they
could keep people's enthusiasm up that
long on this particular issue especially
because our perceptions of President
Trump are already set politically
speaking we all assume president Trump
pays hush money to women why because
he's president Trump as I've said for a
long time the idea that President Trump
is a dirty guy when it comes to women
this has been known there is no there's
nothing new here so the question really
becomes do Democrats really believe that
they can make political hay out of this
for a long period of time and I'm not
sure that the answer is yes and it looks
like they are over their skis if they
start pushing for impeachment on the
basis of what amounts to a campaign
finance violations about him paying off
women when he's been doing that for 20
years and when the criminal indictment
is hanging over his head
president Trump basically tweets that
out over the weekend here is what
President Trump at he said he said
totally clears the president thank you
well no not smudge he's tweeting that
the SD NY memo cleared the President and
at the Moller investigation memo cleared
the president get to the mobile
investigation memo in just a second when
President Trump says it clears him that
is not in fact totally the case he then
continued along these lines he says
after two years and millions of pages of
documents and it cost over 30 million
dollars no collusion we're gonna get to
the Moller memo in just a second so
here's what the Moller memo says now
remember all of this began not with
campaign finance violations which are
the more dangerous powerful President
Trump all of this began with the
accusation that the Trump campaign
coordinated with the Russian government
in order to affect and impact the
outcome of the 2016 election and was
instrumental in hacking of the DNC and
John Podesta Z mails that was the
original accusation that still has not
been proved nothing in the Muller
investigation proves it the Moller
investigation filed a sentencing memo
against Michael
on Friday and here's what you need to
know about that sentencing memo because
there were two sentencing memos about
Cohen one from the SDN why that was
damaging to Trump one from the Muller
investigation that one not so much so
here's what the Muller investigation
memo which was supposed to be the big
fish here's what they say they say that
Cohen's crime was serious that he
withheld material information to the
investigators of the Russia interference
in the 2016 US presidential election
they say that he lied in deliberate and
premeditated fashion and all that began
in a written submission Muller is
focusing in on Cohen's lies about
business that President Trump did with
Moscow according to the sentencing memo
Cohen quote lied to Congress about a
business project the Moscow project that
he worked on during the 2016
presidential campaign while working for
Trump company and for president Trump
personally the goal of such lies was
allegedly to minimize links between the
Moscow project and individual one
president Trump and to give the false
impression that the Moscow project had
ended before the Iowa caucus and the
first presidential primaries in hopes of
limiting the ongoing Russia
investigations being conducted by
Congress in the SEO so cones lies were
obscured by the fact that the Moscow
project was a lucrative business
opportunities that's a that sought and
likely required the assistance of the
Russian government if the project was
completed the company could have
received hundreds of millions of dollars
from Russian sources and licensing fees
and other revenues Miller says Kohn
worked on the project and discussed it
with Trump well into the campaign and
adds the Kohen during the campaign had a
substantive telephone call about the
project with an assistant to the press
secretary for the President of Russia
now a couple of things one Kohn is not
being charged for doing business with
Russia he's being charged for lying to
Muller about doing business with Russia
President Trump lied about doing
business Russia during the campaign or
at least lied about the idea that he had
never done business with Russia during
the campaign but that's not a crime
right that's not criminal so the real
question is what's criminal if Muller
Muller's investigation were to move
toward a criminal indictment of the
president it'd have to be along the
lines that he instructed Michael Cohen
to lie to the authorities I'd have to be
that he that he suborn perjury basically
that would have to be the argument here
because there's nothing illegal about
doing business with the Russians there's
nothing illegal about doing business
with the Russians during the campaign
there's nothing illegal about lying to
the American people about doing business
with the Russians during the campaign
even though it's politically terrible so
what would the actual crime be according
to the sentencing memo the
only crime here would have to be
President Trump telling Cohen to shut
his face when he talked to Muller or lie
when he talked to Muller and that's sort
of what the memo is saying they say the
defendant provided information about
attempts by other Russian nationals to
reach the campaign they said in November
Cohen received the contact information
for and spoke with a Russian national
who claimed to be a trusted person in
the Russian Federation who could offer
the campaign political synergy and
synergy on a governmental level that
never came to fruition it seems like the
allegation here is going to be from
Muller that Trump suborn perjury but
there is no actual claim of that in this
sentencing memo so bottom line the Cohn
investigation New York dangerous to the
president the Muller investigation so
far not so dangerous to the president
now how's the president dealt with all
this the president has swung in quacks
James Comey former FBI director because
we have a controversy over there and
that controversy is justified as well
we'll get to the Comey controversy in
just one second plus the rest of the
White House chaos but before we go any
further does all of this make you
ravenously hungry does all this make you
think man you know what I could really
do right now I could like just curl up
with a cookie I think that pretty much
every hour of the day and that's why I
am so excited to have mrs. field on
board as a sponsor they make amazing
amazing Christmas gifts from her 40
years mrs. fields has a mate has made
delicious treats like their signature
chocolate chip cookies to handcrafted
frosted favorites to melt-in-your-mouth
brownies mrs. Fields gourmet gift tins
and baskets make the perfect presents a
surprise and delight anyone on your list
this season at mrs. Fields their cookies
and sweets are baked daily they always
arrive fresh and flavorful ordering is
easy they can shift your gift ship your
gift anywhere across the United States
plus you can add a personal touch with a
custom message company logo family photo
mrs. Fields even offers a 100% customer
satisfaction guarantee and by the way
there is no way you're going to be
unsatisfied with the mrs. Fields cookie
what are you Hitler
okay everybody how's mrs. Fields Cookies
that's ridiculous
this year send a fresh-baked gift no one
can resist right now get 20% off your
order when you go to mrs. fields calm
and enter promo code Shapiro that's 20%
off any gifts and mrs. fields calm promo
code Shapiro mrs. fields calm promo code
Shapiro get that special offer again if
I were gonna get a gift for Christmas
even though I don't celebrate it would
be this like come on guys send me the
cookies I'm deep
disappointed I've not received enough
mrs. Fields Cookies yet go check it out
mrs. fields comp remote coach Shapiro I
get 20% off any gift right now pretty
awesome
okay meanwhile president Trump has
responded to the Cohen memos by
basically swiveling and clocking James
Comey which is always humorous I have to
say it's always funny when the president
clocks James Comey does James Comey the
worst
the former FBI director is a
grandstanding schmuck of a person the
former FBI director loves him some James
Comey I've always said that find you
somebody who loves you like Jim Acosta
of CNN loves Jim Acosta the same thing
holds true of James Comey he found
himself somebody who loves him like Jim
Acosta loves Jim Acosta he found himself
some James Comey James Comey loved James
Comey he came out today and he said the
proper solution to president Trump's
corruption is for him to be ousted from
office in 2020 I can't imagine why so
many Republicans think that maybe James
Comey was politically driven in 2016
with commentary like that I just can't
imagine a president James Comey came out
over the weekend and he said if Trump
weren't the president he'd be in
jeopardy of being charged this is what
the former FBI director is so he that
they say says that and then it turns out
that James Comey testified in front of
the House Judiciary Committee and their
235 pages of transcript it turns out he
doesn't know and he doesn't remember at
all anything about dozens of questions
concerning key details in the Russia
probe so the accusation made about James
Comey and the FBI is that the original
genesis of the Russia probe was a bunch
of Obama Democrats and Hillary Clinton's
campaign coordinating to launch a an
investigation of President Trump and his
relationships with the Russians and then
on the basis of faulty flawed evidence
that Comey knew was faulty and flawed
they decided to continue that
investigation forthwith and extend it
into a FISA warrant for Carter page so
James Comey was asked about all of this
and it turns out he remembers nothing so
after writing his his book hired loyalty
or whatever it was after writing that
book where he remembered every detail
where he testified in open session of
Congress that he remembered specifically
every detail given contemporaneous memos
suddenly he can't remember at all
whether he knew for example that the
Stila dossier which was used as the
basis for the FISA warrants against
Carter Paige a former trump
foreign-policy eight you can't remember
at all whether he even knew that the
Christopher Steele dossier existed he
can't remember in the slightest
whether that dossier had been
investigated or whether that dossier he
knew was faulty
he just can't remember these things I
mean it's so confusing up there in James
commis head which is like eight feet
from the ground it's so confusing
according to Fox News the former bureau
boss frustrated GOP lawmakers during
Friday's session in large part because
his lawyers are urged him not to answer
numerous questions whom he's expected to
return later in the month for another
round though blasted Republicans on his
way out for what he called a desperate
attempt to find anything that can be
used to attack the institutions of
Justice investigating this president now
a couple of things can be true in all of
this and in fact I think are true number
one Comey is a schmuck who's politically
driven to president Trump's behavior
with regard to Michael Kohn stormy
Daniels Karen McDougal could be a
campaign finance violation it could
certainly be a campaign finance
violation that's possibility three the
Russia investigation could come up
largely empty and reach outs by the
Russian government could have resulted
in nothing I think all three of those
things are likely to be true but the
first thing is certainly true I mean
James Comey is a guy who was politically
driven is pretty obvious he says Comey
insisted in the interview that we never
investigated the Trump campaign for
political purposes but the transcript
shows he claimed ignorance or memory
lapses in response to questions
concerning key details and events in the
Russia investigation we which some GOP
lawmakers continued to claim was
improperly conducted the transcript
reveals lawmakers frustration with his
lack of specifics asked if he recalled
who drafted the FBI's initiation
document for the July 2016 Russian
investigation Comey said I do not he
again claimed not to know when asked
about the involvement in that initiation
of Peter struck whose anti-trump texts
later got him removed from the special
counsels probe when asked if the FBI had
any evidence that anyone in the Trump
campaign conspired to hack the DNC
server coming gave a lengthy answer
referring to Special Counsel Robert
Muller's investigation as to why he
couldn't answer he says I don't think
that the FBI and Special Counsel want me
answering that question that may relate
to their investigation of Russian
interference during 2016 and I worried
that would cross the line when pressed
further by trey Gowdy
representative Gowdy of South Carolina
about what factual predicate the bureau
had to launch a counterintelligence
investigation Comey again claimed that
answering the question would be a slope
they would ask him to reveal what the
FBI
or didn't know about Russian activity as
it relates to the 2016 election Gaudi
asked you can't tell us or he won't tell
us and Comey said probably a combination
of both yeah all of this is deeply
suspicious and does lend credence to the
idea that James Comey and the FBI were
being politically maneuvered by
Democrats by the Obama administration in
an attempt to target president Trump or
at least in an attempt to investigate
President Trump maybe not in an attempt
to destroy his electoral prospects
because remember none of this stuff
leaked until basically after the
election but in an attempt to see if
there was anything perverse about
President Trump's campaign
representative Jim Jordan of Ohio
he says Comey couldn't remember anything
which is weird 245 times he says don't
remember don't recall and don't know
what I'm up was most I guess the biggest
takeaway for me was the don't know part
didn't know that Christopher Steele was
terminated for talking to the press
didn't know he had talked to the press
didn't know they continued to work with
Christopher Steele after he had been
terminated in and continued to get his
information so I was mostly struck by
that here's the key player the guy who
wrote put together the dossier that was
the basis for getting the warrant and
you didn't know anything about him I
find that hard to believe but that that
was those were his answers yesterday
okay all of this is is not great for the
the Trump administration but it's also
very bad for Jim's coming basically our
faith in our institutions has been
shattered at virtually every level
Trump's election is proof that our faith
in our institutions has been shattered
at virtually every level so where does
all of this end up probably with the FBI
having a black eye over its treatment of
the Russia investigation already have a
black eye over their treatment of the
Hillary investigation probably with the
Trump administration from campaign
having a black eye over his hush money
payoffs to women he was having adultery
with and probably with the Muller
investigation I think coming up with far
less than the left thinks that they are
going to come up with although that is
still yet to be seen with all of that
said this is leading to a fair bit of
chaos inside the White House Nick Aires
was basically tapped to be the guy who's
going to take over for chief of staff
John Kelly when Kelly was ousted it's
been rumored for a long time that John
Kelly who's the was the current chief of
staff was going to be leaving in the
very near future he'd been at odds with
the president he'd been at odds with
other top members of the administration
particularly the Jared Kushner part of
the administration and the fact that
Kelly is out is no surprise over the
weekend
Kelly was out
he's leaving and Nick Aires who was
president vice president Mike Pence's
chief of staff was rumored and expected
to be the new chief of staff which would
have at least created a certain level of
solidarity in the upper levels of the
administration because Ayres is very
close with all the other teams he's
close with the foreign policy team he's
close the Pence's team is close
Kushner's team is close with all of
these various teams
well Aires had been tapped and then over
the weekend he was untapped which is not
great news for the administration
because Aires would have been a very
solid pick according to Bloomberg
president Donald Trump said he's
interviewing candidates to replace
outgoing chief of staff John Kelly and
declared it fake news that top vice
presidential aide Nick Ayers had been
certain to get the job before
withdrawing Aires tweeted out Thank You
president Trump vice president and my
great colleagues for the honor to serve
our nation at the White House I will be
departing at the end of the year but
we'll work with the magazine to advance
the cause he's supposed to take over the
super PAC for president Trump's team
when the president tweets that Ayers had
not been the pic that I do not think his
true I I think that is not true I think
that the president is fibbing on that
but now they're in a bit of turmoil as
to who should lead up the chief of staff
position mark Meadows the representative
from South Carolina has been rumored
Meadows that maybe North Carolina but in
any case Meadows had been rumored to be
the guy who was going to take over maybe
Mick Mulvaney has been rumored
scaramouche E has been rumored believe
it or not like that rumor is still
floating around which by the way would
be the greatest fourth season comeback
in history right if if Skinner if the
mooch are back right if the mooch came
back
Wow great TV twist so I'm heavily
rooting for the mooch like I hope the
mooch comes back because entertainment
value folks they'll just be through the
roof we'll get to the impact of all of
that in just a second first I have to
tell you about this amazing graphic
novel series when most people think of
comic books they think superheroes I'm a
huge comic book fan as people who listen
to the show regularly no DC / Marvel
every time but there's a whole world of
comics and graphic novels that is
basically popular fiction dramas
thrillers hired crime more stories that
are new us as a novel but expressed with
unbelievable art one of these is black
powder red earth Yemen I read this over
the weekend it is just tremendous -
graphic novel series told from the
perspective of Special Operations
soldiers
hunting Isis in Yemen and it's all about
the political machinations that are
happening in Yemen the art of it is just
spectacular and beautiful it is
incredibly incredibly beautiful the and
brutal and brutal the story steps into
the event horizon of a failed state
ruthlessly reshaped by civil war radical
Islamic terrorists foreign powers and
private military companies each pushing
the regional conflict to their own
desired end states developed in
collaboration with US Army Special Ops
combat veterans Black Power red earth
Yemen features scenes pulled from real
life and recontextualized for fiction
it's a fiction extrapolated from the
boots on the ground reality of modern
warfare in places like Iraq Syria and
Afghanistan today it is so accurate that
military members actually have consulted
this really in in looking at how
military ops are run you can pick up
black powder red earth Yemen graphic
novels on amazon.com or the website
black powder red earth calm that's black
powder red earth calm it is not for the
faint of heart
it is not for kids this is definitely
for adults or at least or at least late
teenagers and it is awesome awesome
stuff you can learn all about other
black powder red earth projects the
creators are building to include a video
game an animated series a tabletop
wargame all this stuff is great and
really educational as well this is
definitely not a book for kids again it
does have graphic violence and graphic
language but it's awesome it's really
good so for people who are comic book
and graphic novels fans you're gonna
love it go check it out black powder red
earth calm again black powder red earth
calm or check out black powder red earth
Yemen the graphic novels on amazon.com
go check those out right now it's super
cool I mean the art is spectacularly
good okay also we're gonna get to more
of the news and I have a lot to say
about a variety of social justice
warrior issues social media insanity
lots to get to in just a second but
first you're gonna have to go over to
daily wire comm and subscribe right now
so what do you get when you subscribe I
always say you get the rest of my show
live which is true you can see it live
on video they get the rest of Andrew
Clavin show live on video and the rest
of Michael Moses execrable show live on
video and all the rest of that but I
know what you really want is more me and
coming up in 2019 the Ben Shapiro radio
show is extending to three hours that is
correct the Ben Shapiro radio show will
be adding a full two more hours every
day more in-depth content more
commentary phone calls the whole deal
we're adding a full two hours with all
the great content you have come to enjoy
unless you listen live on radio only
subscribers will be able to get the
full three hour show on demand so make
sure to become a daily wire subscriber
today don't miss Andrew klevens final
installment of another Kingdom either
that's performed by Michael Knowles
today subscribers get exclusive access
to episode ten titled The Last Dragon
the story of General Jim mattis if you
are not a subscriber you won't be able
to watch the finale until Friday so what
exactly are you waiting for
we hope you've enjoyed this season of
another kingdom head on over to daily
wire.com subscribe to rewatch the full
first and second seasons and receive
premium access to all upcoming content
we are stacking all of this for
subscribers so much good stuff I
personally am working like a dog like a
dog working these fingers to the bone to
bring you the best possible content
behind that pay wall so go check it out
right now over to daily wire comm $9.99
a month and for $99 a year you get all
of those great things Plus this he left
his tears how to call tumblr view it
behold it look at this wow what
unbelievable
go check it out right now he left his
tears hot or cold tumblr for $99 a year
please also subscribe over at youtube
over at itunes we were the number nine
rated show on all of itunes for 2018
yeah slow clap for our team over here
I'm so good job everybody and thank you
to our listeners and our viewers for
making that happen but we should be
number one next year guys I mean I
expect more of you I do so tell all of
your friends go check it out right now
at YouTube or iTunes leave us a review
that always helps with the rankings we
are the largest fastest growing the most
popular conservative podcast on the
interwebs
[Music]
okay so bottom line is lots of chaos
over at the White House John Kelly is
out Nick Ayers is not in right now
they're a bunch of people who have been
rumored again Republican representative
mark meadows the US Trade Representative
Albert white Heiser apparently he
doesn't want it bunch of director Nicole
Haney apparently doesn't want it acting
Attorney General Matthew Whitaker might
not want it nobody really wants it
because there is so much cast at the
White House and all of that does go to
the president's governing style the
president does not make life easy for
his staffers over the White House it's a
difficult life to be a staffer over at
the White House you're on call all the
time and let's be real about this there
was a lot of chaos in the first couple
of years of the Obama administration as
well but suffice it to say that with the
president doing what the President does
that's a very difficult and unrewarding
job and it'll be interesting to see who
he picks as his chief of staff I just
hope whoever it is is able to bring
together folks inside that
administration in a way that John Kelly
certainly could not and I think Nick
Ayers was sort of poised to now
meanwhile it is worth pointing out that
there is a Supreme Court ruling today I
wasn't really a ruling it was a refusal
to take a writ of certiorari on a on an
abortion case according to National
Review the Supreme Court on Monday
declined to review lower court rulings
that prevented pro-life activists in two
states from ending public financing for
a Planned Parenthood so there was a case
that was going to be appealed to the
Supreme Court about whether States could
ban funding public funding for Planned
Parenthood the cases pertain to whether
a Medicaid recipient who relies on
Planned Parenthood for Health Services
has a right to challenge her state's
decision to defund the organization to
date state courts in Kansas and
Louisiana have found that states violate
federal law by depriving Planned
Parenthood affiliates of Medicaid
funding solely because they provide
abortion the idea is that all of these
federal programs can fund Planned
Parenthood and because they have not
prevented the funding of Planned
Parenthood states can't step in and
prevent the federal government from
funding Planned Parenthood on the
Medicaid level even if the state is
contributing this would be a right
political issue here's the problem there
were three justices three who voted in
favor of hearing the case these would be
your favorite justices Clarence Thomas
Neil Gorsuch Samuel Alito who voted
against hearing the case well all of the
lift all of the leftists on the court
and John Roberts and Brett Kavanaugh who
could have foreseen
that Brett Kavanaugh would not be nearly
as conservative as a lot of his
proponents we're suggesting who could
have suggested mmm
that Brett Kavanaugh might not in fact
be the pro-life warrior on the Supreme
Court that all the people on the Left
thought he was to the extent that they
accused him of rape who could have
foreseen that Brett Kavanaugh would be a
moderate on the court creating a new
swing block with John Roberts hmm who
could right here knows me yeah that's
right go back listen to the shows I said
it at the time so I think this is an
early indicator bet and not a good
indicator that Brett Kavanaugh is going
to be another moderate on the court
which is not exactly what folks need we
need an originalist perspective on the
court we don't need another let's let
all the branches get along with each
other by perverting the Constitution
Clarence Thomas argued that while the
cases do tangentially relate to the
question of abortion that issue is the
more basic question of an individual
Medicaid recipients relationship to her
state government he said it is true that
these particular cases arose after
several states alleged that Planned
Parenthood affiliates had among other
things engaged in the illegal sale of
fetal organs and fraudulent billing
practices and thus removed Planned
Parenthood as a state Medicaid provider
but these cases are not about abortion
rights they're about private rights of
action under the Medicaid Act the
resolving the question presented here
would not even affect Planned Parenthood
ability to challenge States decisions
this of course is correct but that
didn't stop Cavanaugh from preventing
this case from being heard all it takes
to get a Supreme Court writ of
certiorari heard is four justices voting
in favor of hearing the case Cavanaugh
voted against turning the case not a
great early indicator from new justice
Cavanaugh on how he will rule in future
cases not only concerning abortion but
considering hot-button political and
federalism issues okay meanwhile
speaking of hot-button political issues
I got to tell you this story about how
out of control media are so the media
the social media networks right now are
completely out of control I mean
insanely out of control how out of
control over the social media networks
on Sunday there was a kid named Kyler
Murray he just won the Heisman trophies
the Oklahoma quarterback and he became
the subject of a piece from a USA Today
blogger named Scott Gleason what did
Gleason do Gleason wrote an article
shaming Murray immediately are after he
won the Heisman over some tweets he
wrote when he was 14 years old I kid
not Gleason wrote the Oklahoma
quarterbacks memorable night also helped
resurface social media's memory of
several homophobic tweets more than six
years old when Murray was 15 years old
he tweeted at his friends via his since
verified Twitter account using an
anti-gay slur to defame them so Gleason
later updated updated his piece to
include Murray's apology Murray should
not have apologized Gleason should be
fired honestly there is no journalist in
America who should be being paid to dig
up tweets from a 14 year old right after
that person wins the Heisman Trophy
basically you do something prominent in
American life you do something
successful in American life and suddenly
the trolls come out of the woodwork and
what I love most about that USA Today
article from the schmuck Gleeson what I
love the most about it is the way that
it is phrased the quarterbacks memorable
might also help three surface passive
tense social medias memory social media
doesn't have a memory of several
homophobic tweets more than six years
old no what happened is Gleason actively
went and searched out the f-word with
regard to gay people and then he found
some tweets from this kid when the kid
was 14 and now we're gonna destroy
people over what they say when they are
14 and this is the way social media
works now social media have it's no
mercy social media has no standards the
standards are constantly moving we are
not going to pretend that 14 year olds
are immune to this sort of stuff we're
not going to allow people to repent we
saw this last week with Kevin Hart but
we're not we're never going to allow
people to grow and repent and get better
we're simply going to ruin them that's
the way social media works and it gets
even worse in just a second I'm gonna
explain to you how social media have
basically become the new Puritans even
while they push a new standard of
radical left ISM so social media have
basically decided they are the new
arbiters of morality then social media
networks are going to decide the new
morality now for those of us who are
religious the basic idea is that God
sets forth immorality and then he judges
us with both justice and thank God with
mercy but the new god of social media
has no mercy he is a God of justice
alone or she or Z is a God of justice
alone okay that God of justice alone has
a set of rules that are arbitrarily
applied and randomly applied and
randomly changed and that means that
Heisman winning quarterbacks can be
analyzed for their tweets from four or
five years ago that Kevin Hart can be
destroyed on the basis of tweets that he
sent back in 2010 and we can now
back in 2ne1 social media history and
like God looked back into what you
thought ten years ago and then destroy
you over it
they were now extending it forward where
thought crimes that were committed
outside the purview of particular social
media companies can end with banning so
over the weekend patreon which is a
major service that is designed to allow
people to basically have people give
them money for a particular service you
know we have a subscription service over
at the Daily wire but there are lots of
people who offer special services to
their customers via patreon well social
media company patreon decided they were
going to ban a series of people I'm not
a fan of some of these people right so
these people include Milo you innopolis
who I think is a terrible human being
and Jim's Allsop who was a bar they come
a far-right political commentator he's
really just an alt right guy he was
banned from patreon as well
patron also banned Carl Benjamin known
as Sargon of Akkad who is not like Milo
and not like James also the bottom line
is they shouldn't be banning any of
these people if you don't like these
people then maybe you should just
explain why they're wrong and tell
people not to give them money for their
services but patreon has now banned them
without any clear standard of why the
ban happened in the first place this
comes after Alex Jones was banned from
Twitter forever after Apple and Spotify
removed his podcast again I don't have
to agree with any of these people to
recognize that social media has no
standards and they're unevenly applying
those standards as much as they could
possibly want because listen there will
come a point where patreon bans me I'm
not on patreon but if I were they would
ban me where patreon or Facebook or
Twitter come after me or they come after
Jordan Peterson or they come after Dave
Rubin or they come after Mark Levin or
they come after Sean Hannity or they
come after everyone who they disagree
with on any level that's the way these
social media companies are working why
because they are radically disconnected
from real life now
I've recommended on the show before the
HBO show Silicon Valley and it's a
hilarious show the basic premise of the
show is that there's a guy who's trying
to start a media company in Silicon
Valley but one of the main stars of the
show is a guy who's pretty obviously
based on the heads of Google a guy named
Gavin Belson that's the character on
Silicon Valley and Gavin Belson is a
self-aggrandizing new-agey jerk who
pretends that he is soft and cuddly when
in
reality he's the harshest most terrible
person and he spends all of his time
trying to force his business down on
everyone he's he basically says that his
job is to not do evil in the same way
that Google's job is not to do evil
except that all he does throughout the
show is do evil but he pretends that
he's actually spiritual and enlightened
I need to show you this clip from
Silicon Valley to explain how it is that
social media works in Silicon Valley so
this is so spot on here's here's Gavin
Belson from Silicon Valley talking to a
guru who he flew in in order to talk to
about spirituality what's weighing on
you Gavin
Jared done quit today to join Pied Piper
I hate Richard Hendricks little Pied
Piper is is that wrong in the hands of a
lesser person but in the hands of the
enlightened hate can be a tool for great
change you're right
once again oh yeah the reason I bring
this up is because this is exactly what
how do I know this is what Silicon
Valley is because over the weekend Jack
Dorsey who's the CEO of Twitter had a
series of tweets in which he morphed
into Gavin Belson now I don't know how
Mike judge the creator of Silicon Valley
somehow got Jack Dorsey to become Gavin
Belson but he did Jack Dorsey tweeted
this out Myanmar which is a place known
for like it's genocide right now is an
absolutely beautiful country the people
are full of joy and the food is amazing
I visited the cities of Yangon man's
alayan Bagon we visited and meditated at
many monasteries around the country and
then he continued the highlight of my
trip was serving monks and nuns food and
donating sandals and umbrellas this
group of young nuns in Mandalay and
their chanting was breathtaking and
chilling and then we get to my best part
we also meditated in a cave in Mandalay
one evening in the first ten minutes I
got bit 117 times by mosquitoes they
left me alone when the light blew a fuse
which you can see in my heart rate
lowering so good hey I also wore my
Apple watch an aura ring both in
airplane mode my best meditations always
had the least variation in heart rate
when I wasn't focused it would jump
around a lot here's the night of sleep
on the 10th night my resting heart rate
was consistently below 40 he says
Vipassana is not for everyone but if any
of this resonates with you and even the
slightest I'd encourage you to give it a
try ok so the reason that I bring this
up is because this
what Silicon Valley is in the end it's a
bunch of self-aggrandizing radical
leftist jerks who spend their days
pretending to like meditation so they
convert you signal to all their friends
while banning people who disagree with
them politically
that's what Silicon Valley has become
and we're supposed to take these people
seriously as our moral arbiter but
that's exactly what they do there are
moral arbiters now because they can
mobilize the mob or they can be
mobilized by the mob to go after people
on a regular basis it's astonishing it's
astonishing so before you think social
media has the capacity to control
decency recognize that the people who
run social media are Gavin Belson's
they're not in fact Saints okay
meanwhile I have to talk about a couple
of stories that are just insane you know
maybe we'll save those stories for
tomorrow shoo save those stories for
morrow probably okay so we'll do things
I like and then we'll do a couple of
things that I hate okay so things that I
like today there's a great book that
I've been reading over the weekend
called American dialog by Joseph Ellis
the founders in us Joseph Ellis is
winner of the Pulitzer Prize and this
book is basically about controversial
issues from the founders perspective and
from our own so he took he looks at
issues like race what did the founders
think on racial issues where were they
wrong where were they right when they
were talking about the Constitution was
that supposed to be a document that
enshrined racism and one that fought it
it's a it's a deep and useful book
people who who pretend that the founders
were not deep thinkers on a variety of
issues but we're really just protecting
their own sort of property and interest
ought to read this book in a lot more
history the fact is that the founders
were in fact deep thinkers with eternal
ideas and even if they were men bound by
their time there were also people who
were thinking beyond the bounds of their
time and it's our job to determine what
in their thought was eternal and what
was bound by the limitations of the time
in which they lived okay other things
that I like so this was just spectacular
if if you did not see the Miami Dolphins
New England Patriots game last night I'm
gonna show you the last seven seconds of
this game because it was one of the best
things I've ever seen in NFL football
just amazing here is the Miami Dolphins
who are down to their last play seven
seconds left first in ten from their own
30 yard line and here is what happens
seven seconds left
[Applause]
and this will end it after the shuttle
go real
[Applause]
chuckling
unbelievable unbelievable snow it's also
fun to see that done against the New
England Patriots for everybody so
amazing so I had to show that to you
because when there's a great sports play
I just can't resist okay
with all of that happiness put aside a
time for some things I really hate it's
a worst story of the day obviously on
Sunday seven Israelis were wounded in a
drive-by shooting near the town of Oprah
which is approximately 13 miles north of
Jerusalem the scorn of Frank camp over
its daily wire one of the critically
wounded is a 21 year old pregnant female
following the violent attack the woman
was taken to Shire it's a tack hospital
where doctors successfully delivered her
baby the baby is currently in critical
condition and the woman is also in
critical but stable condition her
husband was lightly wounded as well The
Times of Israel spoke with a surgeon dr.
Allon Schwartz who said the woman had
lost a lot of blood as a result of the
gunshot wound to her stomach according
to an IDF spokesperson quoted by Aras
Sheva which is a right-wing Israeli news
outlet following the previous report
regarding the shooting attack adjacent
to the Ophir injunction shots were fired
from a passing Palestinian vehicle
toward Israeli civilians who are
standing at the bus station
IDF troops who were present nearby
responded by firing toward the suspect
vehicle which fled so what did Hamas do
Hamas has welcomed the shooting attack
in which a pregnant Israeli woman and
six others were wounded they call it a
blessed demonstration of the ability of
the resistance to hurt the enemy in its
most sensitive places it is worth noting
that the UN General Assembly refused to
vote to condemn Hamas about three days
ago so whenever people talk about the
morality of the UN just remember the UN
is a it is the most Eisley of world
politics the UN is a hive of scum and
villainy the UN is a is a collection of
garbage run countries people countries
run by people who are sheer garbage and
those people refuse to even vote to
condemn an open terrorist group that
celebrates when a pregnant woman is shot
in the stomach and her baby is barely
delivered alive that's what the UN is so
anytime you hear about the morality of
the UN oo the UN has passed a bunch of
resolutions who gives a flying F I don't
when the UN passes a resolution you can
fairly guarantee that 95% of the time
it's a resolution predicated toward
forwarding evil not or preventing it so
spare me all of your nonsense about UN
resolutions condemning Israel or the UN
doesn't like us enough the United States
we have to be more friendly with UN
how about we look at the constituency of
the UN and look the fact that I won't
condemn actual terrorists and then maybe
we consider whether or not we ought to
take our cues from countries like Syria
countries like Yemen whether we ought to
take our cues from the Russians it's
unbelievable the same people who are
complaining the President Trump is in is
in league with the Russians are happy to
endorse Russian foreign policy at every
prospect at the United Nations it's it's
truly amazing the same people who
complain that the Trump administration
is too close to the Saudis they're happy
to take the cues from the Saudis at the
UN and they complain when the United
States doesn't do it enough the UN as
I've said before I am not in favor of
eminent domain and overuse of it I'm not
in favor of the idea that in the United
States you should be able to take
private property transfer it to another
party for purposes of increasing tax
revenue as the Supreme Court decided in
kilo versus New London bad ruling but I
don't even care if President Trump wants
to raise the UN building to the ground
and build a Trump Tower on top of it I'm
all in favor of it the UN is gross and
we should pull out of it as soon as
humanly possible it is just an awful
awful place okay other things that I
hate today
so I have to I just have to point this
out Alexandre Ocasio Court has a if she
wouldn't say so many stupid things I
wouldn't have to talk about her saying
so many stupid things you think I want
to talk about this woman I want to talk
about this woman and every time I talk
about her it gets I get from the
left-wing media
oh you're obsessed with Alexandra Ocasio
cortes no as you know from listening to
the show I'm obsessed with stupidity in
all of its forms
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez showed up on
Hanukkah she little synagogue of course
because she is an advocate of boycott
divestment and sanctions an anti-semitic
policy directed at the elimination of
the Jewish state she showed up to
explain that sure she may be in league
with anti-semites like Kilohana Mara and
Rashid its vibe sure she may be good
friends with Linda Sarsour but at least
way back when she's part Jewish you know
it's not just Alexandra Kazmir Cortez
who's done this I remember John Kerry
did this arm poor Jewish if you go back
far enough arm poor Jewish I'm asleep
which part man and then Hillary Clinton
I remember at one point in the early
2000s when she was running for office in
New York City I'm part Jewish just okay
you know what I don't care I don't care
if you're part Jewish
I really don't what I care about is what
you think and what you feel and what
exactly you're going to implement in
your daily life but here is Alexandra
Ocasio Cortez suddenly rediscovering her
Jewish roots
generations ago my family consisted of
Sephardic Jews and although all the old
liberal Jews were like oh isn't that so
sweet
isn't that so wonderful it's like no
it's not what is she doing what it like
what are her policies like any Jew who's
taken in by the I have a relative who's
Jewish argument okay it's not it's no
better in argument than when people
accuse somebody of racism they're like
well one time I was friends with a black
guy okay this is even this is even worse
at least when somebody says I was
friends the black guy that has to do
with their behavior I had a great great
great great great grandmother who once
took the Jew is not exactly a great
argument for why you're a pro Jewish
politician or a pro-israel politician or
anything with the like I hate that I
hate that sort of politics with a with a
burning fiery passion other things that
I hate today there's a high school
teacher who has now been fired for
failing to use a transgender students
preferred pronoun a Virginia high school
teacher was fired because he wouldn't
use a preferred pronoun of a female
student who claimed that she was now a
male the unanimous decision from the
five members of the West Point School
Board to fire Peter flaming a French
teacher at the West Point High School
which has roughly 265 students followed
a four-hour hearing the board only
discussed the case for an hour before
rendering their decision Richmond calm
reports and flaming who's 47 had taught
at the high school for almost 7 years
and had taught the student in the
2017-2018 school year when the students
still identified his female over the
summer of 2018 the girl decided she was
a boy this school year
blaming addressed the girl by the new
name she had chosen but would not use
the girls preferred a new pronoun
because it conflicted with landings
Christian faith now he didn't go out of
his way to call the girl a girl he
didn't go out of his way to say she
every time we talked about her instead
he attempted to avoid using any sort of
gender pronouns at all because he didn't
want to use biologically incorrect
pronouns and he was fired for this
because he was insensitive apparently
apparently it's insensitive if you
refuse to use biologically incorrect
pronouns even if you are attempting to
not use any pronouns at all even if
you're trying to be sensitive enough not
to offend the student by using no gender
pronouns at all now if you refuse to use
the gender pronouns that somebody wants
used now you will be fired for it the
student claimed she felt singled out
the only reference to flaming actively
calling the girl by the female pronoun
rather than her name
according to witnesses came on Halloween
when the student was using a VR headset
as the student is about to bump into a
wall blemings told students to stop her
that incident prompted a discussion with
administrators so if you accidentally
get it wrong while you're trying to be
sensitive you will be fired okay this is
a serious First Amendment issue can
school districts force you to use
biologically incorrect pronouns to refer
to students is that something that we
can do in a First Amendment loving
Society can state schools force you to
do these things under the rubric of
anti-discrimination it's why I've always
been very skeptical of a lot of the
anti-discrimination laws pushed by the
left I think that they are Trojan horses
for an attempt to cram down force force
on people's use of free speech and this
is just the latest example in West Point
high school principal Jonathan Hawkman
testified he had instructive landing to
use the students new pronoun said I
can't think of a worse way to treat a
child than what was happening really you
can't think of any worse way to treat
the child then using gender non-binary
pronouns I can think of a lot of worse
ways to treat a child I think those ways
generally would include very often
people humoring the the mental illness
of people when they are small and then
encouraging them to sterilize themselves
through hormone treatment I think that's
usually a bad thing also West Point
School Superintendent Laura Abel stated
that discrimination then leads to a
hostile learning environment the student
expressed that the parents had expressed
that they felt disrespected
Voyles countered that as a public
employee blaming had a right to free
speech adding one of those rights that
is not curtailed is to be free from
being compelled to speak something that
violates your conscience and this is all
ridiculous the teacher was going out of
his way not to offend the student and
accidentally used be biologically
correct pronoun once and now is being
fired for it this is where our country
is going and it's going to get uglier
and uglier because the left demands that
you be forced to care you will be forced
to care okay well we will be back here
tomorrow with all of latest I'm sure
there will be lots of breaking news and
there are a couple stories I didn't
cover today that I cannot wait to cover
tomorrow we'll get to those in the
future I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Alex and Garo audio is
mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is
by Jess wah
of era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018